[Music]
the album is for everyone but I wrote it
from my sort of experience in love any
relationships in general and I would say
that's sort of what I'm pulling from is
my human experience in relationships but
also just my experience as a black woman
in America and in the world is sort of
like larger context so when I write
lyrics I'm thinking about lyrics that
are really safe for black women
specifically to sing if it's safe for a
black woman and if it's empowering for a
black woman to sing it's gonna be
empowering for everybody else
[Music]
okay so you excited Janet Jackson
there's like a big influence on your
work yeah I just want to know what like
you honored to come to the Super Bowl do
you have any thoughts on that whole
ordeal yeah I there's a part of me that
that wants her to get it you know and
wants her to get up you know but there's
a part of me that also wants her to
protest I mean not protest in the
traditional sense but I guess there's a
way that I I'd also be down for a
boycott on the AFL in general like might
be time for just all the black people to
be like you know what like can't can't
entertain y'all right now not gonna sing
a dance I'm not doing not shucking and
jiving right now because it's too urgent
I think that that's something I would be
I've always wanted you know sport is one
of the places where we can see how how
how backwards our hierarchies are and
it's really weird that through sport you
can reason through racism you know
because you can say that this is the
only time that we can all get together I
mean sport is generally about putting
your self you know your your belief
system aside to create team and
camaraderie but I think what's actually
happened under the guise of camaraderie
is something really sick and twisted and
dark and quite slave slave like you know
it's just harkens back to something that
has already existed in this country so I
want Janet to pick up her check you know
I want her to get the check and I want
her to get the visibility and sort of
establish herself but like I mean the
way they did her with the last time that
she played with just
I'm Timberlake I think he's also another
sort of anecdotal you know horrible
moment because I think that that really
affected her career and things changed
for her after that moment for it for
Justin Timberlake everything was on the
rise on the up and up and I think that's
something that not a lot of people have
observed I don't think that they saw
that you didn't hear about Janet but you
definitely heard about Justin after that
and I would also like to ask Justin to
step up on that hey Justin
[Music]
you know a woman or man coming forward
against someone a lot of it is happening
in TV world but you think that's that
kind of behavior exists well oh yeah it
definitely does and there were several
accounts before that this one in the
music you know industry there there was
a period where a few men were being
called out at the same time this one is
a weird one for me to answer because
even though it's an issue that affects
me and sort of implicated in that the
voice the the people who have spoken up
and sort of you know said this is wrong
in a very public way our white women and
the way that I don't know the feminist
conversation around these issues
sort of
just kind of I've always felt excluded
from that conversation and so it's a
weird one for me to jump in as a black
woman on that because there's a way that
white women haven't rallied around our
issues and haven't asked you know
there's just there's a tradition there's
a long story around this and it's too
long to get into right now but I'll just
say that that's a really complex and
layered thing for a black woman to chime
in on reflexively because there's just a
lack of protection when I say something
there's a way that it won't get taken as
seriously than if a white woman said
that was really wrong and you know so
like also the way that I the way that
I'm not allowed to protest those types
of things and still get attention and
still keep my human sorry and and still
being able to keep my sort of career
moving forward and up is is just a
different set of constraints and sort of
just stuff to deal with of course I am
against any abuse and just would call it
out you know but there is just oh
there's a lot more going on than just
social justice someone said the only
reason this is getting so much publicity
is because all the women are famous
that's the only reason if I were to say
the same things it would just not hold
the same way there we have a tradition
of being highly concerned about white
women especially if they're blonde and
they you know are classically beautiful
in that sort of pristine white way I
think that there's just a way that yeah
when it comes to like even missing
people you know missing girls when a
white girl goes missing the whole
country is just you know up up in arms
went black girls you know Brown girls go
missing all the time
and it's just not doesn't get the same
attention yeah well it's
[Music]
so you've done a lot of chlorine sponge
yeah what collaborated with her once yes
you know we collaborate in our minds and
in our hearts yeah she's one of my
favorite people on the planet she's
provided me with a lot of Solace just a
lot of like feeling safe feelings you
know in a context that just has not felt
very safe and yeah we I don't know what
does she like she's an incredible human
being